it is important to be clear that the OB
R's numbers are not a forecast or a
prediction
they simply set out what one possible
scenario might look like and it may not
even be the most likely scenario but
it's important that we are honest with
people about what might be happening in
our economy so before I turn to today's
how figures I want to spend a few
minutes explaining what the OVR have
said and let me thank them for their
continued work there are three brief
points I wanted to make first the Obiang
figures suggest that the scale of what
we are facing will have serious
implications for our economy here at
home in common with other countries
around the world these are tough times
and there will be more to come as I've
said before we can't protect every
business and every household but we came
into this crisis with a fundamentally
sound economy powered by the hard work
and ingenuity of the British people and
British businesses so while those
economic impacts are significant the obr
also expect them to be temporary where
they bounce back in growth the second
point I want to make is that we're not
just going to stand by and let this
happen our planned economic response
it's protecting millions of jobs
businesses self-employed people
charities and households our response
aims to directly support people and
businesses while the restrictions are in
place and to make sure that as the
restrictions are changed we can as
quickly as possible get people back to
work get businesses moving again and
recover our economy the obr today have
been clear that the policies we have set
out will do that
the OVR today have been clear that if we
had not taken the actions we have the
situation would be much worse
in other words our plan is the right
plan the third point I want to make is
this right now the single most important
thing we can do for the health of our
economy is to protect the health of our
people it's not a case of choosing
between the economy and public health
common sense tells us that doing so
would be self-defeating at a time when
we are seeing hundreds of people dying
every day from this terrible disease the
absolute priority must be to focus all
of our resources not just of the state
but of businesses and all of you at home
as well in a collective national effort
to beat this virus the government's
approach is to follow scientific and
medical advice through our step-by-step
action plan aiming to slow the spread of
the virus so fewer people need hospital
treatment at any one time protecting the
NHS's ability to cope I said in my
budget a month ago that whatever the NHS
needs it will get and we have honored
that promise yesterday we published an
update showing that we've given our
public services an extra 14 and a half
billion pounds in recent weeks we are
taking action to increase NHS capacity
with more beds more key staff and more
equipment on the frontline and the
Secretary of State for Health and Social
Care we'll be updating on our plans for
Social Care tomorrow this is why we are
instructing people to stay at home so
that we can protect our NHS and save
lives I can report that through the
government's ongoing monitoring and
testing program as of today three
hundred and two thousand five hundred
and ninety nine people in the UK have
now been tested for coronavirus with
ninety three thousand eight hundred and
seventy three people testing positive
nineteen thousand seven hundred and six
people in the UK have been
admitted to hospital with the virus down
from 20,000 184 people yesterday sadly
of those in hospital 12,000 107 people
have now died an increase of 778
fatalities since yesterday
our thoughts are with the family and
friends of all those who have lost their
lives
these figures are a powerful reminder to
us all of the importance of following
the government's guidance stay at home
protect our NHS and save lives